Welcome back.
So where we left off is, there
was 1,000 people who all
needed, let's say, $1
million loans each.
And they were all going to
pay 10% on their loans.
And they borrowed it
from this bank.
It's kind of a standard
commercial bank.
And this bank says, well you
know, I just handed out $1
billion and I'm getting these
interest payments.
And my vaults are empty.
I want to have money
back in my vaults.
Or I want to have money back
on my balance sheet.
So I'm going to sell
these loans.
I'm going to bundle them all
together and sell them to this
investment bank.
And now what is this investment
bank going to do
with these loans?
And why is it doing it?
So let me delete this.
So we had the investment bank.
I randomly picked the color
green, but I think it is
appropriate for the
investment bank.
So now I have all of the, you
know, me-- that's a little
smiley face.
There's 1,000 of me, and we are
now going to pay the 10%.
We're now going to make all of
our mortgage payments, the 10%
payment, to this bank,
this investment bank.
But the investment bank, they're
not in the business of
servicing loans or keeping loans
on their balance sheets.
So what they do is, they
create a corporation.
They create an entity, maybe
a special purpose entity,
whatever you want to call it.
So they create a company.
Let me make that in purple,
another color.
So they created this company.
And what they do is, they will
take their rights to these
payments that they got.
Right?
They paid $1 billion to that
first bank in order to get the
payments from all
of these people.
And they say, you know what?
The rights on those payments--
that's the asset.
They bought all these loans.
The rights on those payments,
we are now going to transfer
to this special purpose
entity, to this other
corporation.
So now everyone is going to,
essentially-- all their
mortgage payments are going to
be funnelled into this entity.
Right?
And this is a corporation.
And so what the bank will do
is issue shares in this
corporation.
So let's say that it issues,
let's sat for simplicity, a
hundred shares.
So what's in this corporation?
The entire corporation gets the
mortgage payments on the
$1 billion in loans, right?
It has $1 billion of
loans outstanding.
And it is going to
get 10% a year.
So it's going to get $100
million per year right?
Because it's a thousand
loans out there.
It's going to get $100 million
per year for 10 years.
And at the end of the 10 years
it's also going to get $1
billion, right?
That's its asset it has.
Its asset is the rights on those
payments streams that
are going to come into
this corporation.
And it has 100 shares.
The way I think about
is you can split
this company 100 ways.
And I'm doing this to
further confuse you.
So what is each of those-- the
owner of each of those shares,
what does it entitle them to?
Well, it entitles me to 1/100 of
what this corporation gets.
So if I have a share-- let's
make it look like a share, a
stock certificate-- I'm going
to get 1/100 of this thing.
And normally you wouldn't
have 100 shares.
You would have, let's say,
a million shares.
Actually let me make it a
million shares, just because I
think that's, in some strange
way, more realistic.
So let's say there are
a million shares.
So if there are 1 million
shares, each share will get 1
millionth of the cash
flow stream that's
entitled to this entity.
So instead of getting $100
million every year, it gets
one millionth of that.
So it gets $100 per year.
And then on the last year,
instead of getting $1 billion
it gets $1000.
So what the bank will do is
it'll take these shares and
then it'll sell it to
the general public.
It'll IPO it, essentially.
You can think of it that way.
And tons of people will buy it,
especially hedge funds,
and pension funds, and mutual
funds, and bond investors.
And it's important to think
about how the money's flowing.
So now when they sell these
shares in this entity, people
are going to give them, well,
hopefully more than what they
paid for it, right?
Maybe there's a lot of demand
for this type of asset, where
I get this type of
income stream.
So maybe once they sell all the
shares, they get, I don't
know, they get $1.1 billion
for them, right?
So this is the investors.
And the investors collectively
buy these
shares for $1.1 billion.
Essentially, let's say they
paid $1.1 billion for a
million shares, so they
paid $1,100 per share.
Right?
Each of the investors paid
$1,100 for each of these
shares, so that $1.1 billion
goes into this
special purpose entity.
And if you think about
it, the bank made out
like a bandit, right?
Because the bank paid $1 billion
for the rights to
these mortgage payments, and
it's getting $1.1 billion from
the investors.
And all the bank has to do is
kind of set this whole legal
structure up and service
the loans.
It actually doesn't even have
to service the loans.
We'll go into that later.
So let me summarize, I guess.
Just because I know this
can be a little bit
of a daunting subject.
Let me summarize.
And this purple I don't like.
Anyway.
So you have tons of investors.
So, each of these
is an investor.
Actually a mortgage,
a borrower.
All of these people need
to buy houses.
These are all smiley faces.
They all need to buy houses.
And then they collectively
get $1 billion.
Right? $1 million each.
And they each use that $1
million to buy their house.
And then that $1 billion
initially came from just their
local bank.
And when the $1 billion came
from that local bank, all the
payments, the interest payments,
went to the bank.
But then an investment bank came
along and said, well no,
I want to buy the rights
to those payments.
And an investment bank came
along and says, well, I'm
going to give you $1 billion.
And now instead of
you getting the
payments, I get the payments.
And then the bank sets up a
special purpose entity.
Essentially it sells
a bunch of shares.
Let's say it sells
a million shares.
And let's say it was able to
sell each of those shares for
$1,100 from the investing
public.
So it raises $1.1
billion, right?
So the value of this company is
$1.1 billion that now goes
to the bank.
And now the payment stream
instead of going to-- let me
do a different color-- now the
payment stream goes to this
special purpose entity
instead of the bank.
And the bank essentially made
out like a bandit because it
paid $1 billion and it got $1.1
so it made $100 million
just for doing this
transaction.
I'm not saying that's how much
a bank actually would make,
but this shows you why every
person is kind of, what
they're doing in this
value chain.
And as I said before, this
bank also probably did
something similar.
They probably took some fees or
sold the loans for slightly
more than they issued
the loans for.
So these shares-- each of these
one million shares--
this is a mortgage-backed
security.
And it makes sense.
It's a security.
A security is an ownership
that's tradable in a company.
And that company has the right
to payments that are secured
by mortgages.
So if all these people promised
they would pay, and
they're going to pay to this
special purpose entity.
But if, by chance, one of these
people lose their jobs
or they can't pay, or for
whatever reason, instead of
the payments, this entity is
going to have the rights to
their property.
And that's why we
say that it's a
mortgage-backed security.
So it's not just a promise
to get money.
The money is actually backed
by people's mortgages.
And of course, then this entity
is going to, if this
guy defaults on his loan--
he's one of a million, so
statistically you might be
able to predict that.
I don't to put too much stock in
these statistical models--
then this entity will just have
that property auctioned
off or sold.
And the cash flow will
come back to it.
So that's what a mortgage-backed
security is.
Hopefully I didn't confuse
you too much.
My next presentation, I'm going
to take it to a further
level of confusion and show you
what a collateralized debt
obligation is.
And then I'll do a more
philosophical video on why
these things even exist, and
why they're useful, and why
people may benefit or may not
benefit from these things.